The Soviet Superman Red Son
If you’ve ever sat around thinking, “What
if Superman was a communist?”
(Who hasn’t, right?)
Well, wonder no more.
The answer was masterfully provided in Superman:
Red Son written by famed comic book writer
and member of the “Most Excellent Order
of the British Empire”, Mark Millar.
The specific comic book in question was a
mini-series (3 issues) published by DC Comics
in 2003 and is a true gem of comic art.
For this mini-series, Millar came up with
a unique and brilliant concept.
In his own words,
Instead of landing in Kansas as a child, I’ve
decided to explore what could have happened
if his rocket would have landed on a collective
farm in the Soviet Union.
Instead of working for the Daily Planet, he’ll
be a reporter for Pravda.
There’s a reversal of the current situation,
this time it’s the U.S.A. that’s splitting
up with Georgia and Louisiana demanding independence
– tanks rolling through the streets of New
Orleans.
I’ll be including a whole bunch of DC characters,
like Batman and Green Lantern – who you’ll
see in a new light.
What inspired Millar to write such a version
of Superman’s history?
Red Son is based on a thought that flitted
through my head when I read Superman #300
as a six year old.
It was an imaginary story where Superman’s
rocket landed in neutral waters between the
USA and the USSR and both sides were rushing
to claim the baby.
As a kid growing up in the shadow of the Cold
War, the notion of what might have happened
if the Soviets had reached him first just
seemed fascinating to me.
As I got older, I started putting everything
together and I first pitched something to
DC when I was thirteen, I think – although
it was in a much cruder form, of course, and
my drawings weren’t quite up to scratch.
With time and a lot of hard work, Millar gained
significant experience , which allowed him
to, after a decade in the business, finally
publish Superman: Red Son.
Reading the comic book today, one can tell
that Millar never varied (significantly) from
his original idea for the story.
In the story, Superman indeed lands in the
Ukraine and not in Kansas.
He was raised as a proud Soviet, who was taught
to love and serve the communist principals
of the Soviet Union, but he’s still the
same compassionate, fair, courageous and fearless
superhero who loves humanity more than anything.
He still obeys his super hearing and responds
to every call for help.
His favorite “habit” remains saving lives.
Despite the similarities, however, there are
significant differences that can’t go unnoticed.
For example, he is not the geeky journalist
that we expect him to be.
Instead, he becomes a high ranking officer
of the Communist Army.
His identity is not simply a private secret
he hides, but a state secret that the government
of his country helps him hide.
His uniform doesn’t carry the popular Superman
shield and, instead, carries the symbol of
the communist Soviet Union: The hammer and
sickle.
Superman is not fighting for “truth, justice,
and the American Way” and, instead, is “the
champion of the common worker who fights a
never-ending battle for Stalin, socialism
and the international expansion of the Warsaw
Pact.”
Indeed, at a certain point during the story,
Superman becomes the undisputed leader of
the Soviet Union and then the world.
Another relevant difference is Lois Luthor
-yes Luthor- the first lady of the United
States, married to Lex Luthor, who is still
an amoral genius and remains Superman’s
#1 enemy.
As for the end of the story?
I recommend you read it because it’s fantastic.
But if you just want the gist of it instead
of hours of entertainment, major spoiler alert
ahead.
Briefly, eventually Superman realizes his
world conquest is wrong and tries to turn
back, but is attacked by one he thought was
his ally.
This supervillain is defeated by Luthor.
In the meantime, Superman ends up saving the
world by taking said supervillain’s ship,
which is powered by singularities that are
about to collapse, out into space where the
singularities do, indeed, collapse.
At this point, it would seem Superman is dead.
Luthor takes back over creating a world-wide
United States and our planet is at peace.
Thanks to medical advancements, Luthor is
able to live for many centuries.
When he does die, Superman in the guise of
a more traditional Clark Kent attends Luthor’s
funeral.
Here’s the twist.
Fast-forward billions of years and the Earth
is being destroyed by the Sun in its Red Giant
phase.
That’s when one of Lex Luthor’s descendents,
Jor-L, puts his son in a rocket.
After his journey, his son, Kal-L, ends up
landing in the Ukraine
in 1938.